I think writing the impulse to write
comes out of a failure to communicate by
any other means I think most natural
writers are socially incompetent and I
would include myself generously in that
category especially as a child and in my
early adulthood and and and yeah often
is not it parties for example I still
feel like a 13 year old
fish-out-of-water
would prefer to crawl off in a corner
with a book when you when talking only
works so well and you know that feeling
of of having had an encounter with
someone and later you think what you
should have said well writing is all
about being able to rewrite history and
get it what you should have said it's a
it's a way and it's a way of writing
subtext you know that's the thing is
that with social interaction it's always
got more than one layer and that's very
frustrating and with people with whom
we're trying to be intimate we're always
fighting to get down to the layers and
it seems that no matter how many layers
you go down there's another one that you
haven't really tapped and writing is is
an effort and sometimes a failed effort
as well to get down to the bottom layer
I'm a big fan of Edith Wharton I love
the way she writes elegantly without
without being fussy
she writes beautiful sentences they're
well constructed and balanced but
they're never just beautiful sentences
they always say something to me that's
the essence of a beautiful sentence it's
not just pretty in its language but it
gets at something some kind of truth or
or essence that is revelatory and she
she embodies that for me she's also a
great storyteller oh and writes
wonderful characters I'm also a huge fan
of Richard Yates I feel I have a real
affinity with his perspective on the
world which is a little bit sour but
also also has a sense of humor and I I
love the way he writes characters that
is it on the one hand in a lot of ways
he's taking the mickey out of them as
they say in Britain that is he's he's
exposing them but he's exposing them
that in a way that is short of ridicule
Yates still has a tenderness toward his
characters even characters that are that
are being used a bit for Laughs or you
know maybe maybe shallow or pretentious
but there's always something poignant
about that and sympathetic and I like
that I'm not sure I always managed to
pull that off into my own work but when
I do I feel I've really achieved
something because as much as it's
satisfying to expose people's foibles
it's it's its most satisfying to do that
in a way that that is empathetic with
those foibles which sees them from the
inside and and how they might have come
about and and has an element of
forgiveness
in the portrait
there's nothing occult about what I do
it is very ordinary I'm often asked at
literary festivals for example you know
how many hours a day do you write and
when do you write and do you have a set
number of pages that you ride and the
answer is you know it varies enormously
I used to be much more insecure about my
capacity to generate a manuscript and so
that when I first started out and I'm
sure a lot of younger writers will
recognize this you know I I I started at
a particular time I had to write three
pages a day now I'm not like that at all
maybe maybe someday I'll write nothing
some another day maybe I'll write 10
pages the secret is just to keep at it
and and putting the time and it doesn't
matter what what the time of day is it's
a very work a day plodding profession
especially writing books you're better
off not waiting for inspiration I find
inspiration is something that you demand
of yourself that that will arrive in due
course if you sit in front of the
computer long enough you just have to
concentrate so you know I got up in the
morning having a whacking big cup of
coffee read the newspaper I have to say
that's an important part of my life is
is keeping up with current events I'm
especially attentive to the little
articles I think for a writer those
little sidebar arty articles are are the
jewels of the news day tiny little
incidents that are usually on a more
individual level and not like peace
talks in the Middle East and I love
those and I'm somebody who fanatically
clips those articles I've got whole
files full of bits and pieces from
newspapers and
then I answer my email which takes in an
atrocious amount of time and finally I
get down to work
I guess the on an advice level the only
other the only other advice I dish out
is that the one kind of counterpoint
important part of my day is getting
getting a lot of exercise at the end of
it because it's such a sedentary
profession that that otherwise it's
innervating when you get enough exercise
it keeps your energy levels up so
anybody who out there who who writes
should also learn to run
occasionally I don't use them as much as
I I I think I will or I should I think
they more function along the lines of
giving me a sense of narrative
possibility all the weird little plots I
mean reality is so much stranger than
you could ever make up and I like to be
reminded of that